clément gignac économiste en chef à
l'industrielle-alliance bonsoir est ce
qu'il faut
est-ce qu'il est acceptable est
approprié de ne rien dire d'un retour à
une forme d'équilibré budgétaire ou de
contrôle des dépenses publiques et de
dire simplement nous devons continuer à
injecter beaucoup beaucoup d'argent dans
l'économie mais c'est acceptable dans ce
sens que tellement d'incertitudes
actuellement que ce serait même pas
crédible de présenter un plan le 2 de
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire ou faire
des projections sur cinq
et attendez-vous d'ailleurs un budget
cet automne ça va des centres auto
l'été suivant pour avoir une visibilité
ce un vaccin ou qu'on puisse savoir bon
que la deuxième vague est derrière nous
et on ne trouve un vaccin dont dans ce
sens là je suis pas très surpris qu'on
ait un discours du trône qui des manques
sont va avoir un plein qu'on va soutenir
les travailleurs ou les entreprises
mais ce qui me surprend dans ce disque
où dit on au giral c'est carrément
l'intervention c'est un
interventionnisme un moyen long terme
dans l'économie et interventions main
dans les champs de juridiction des
provinces d'assurance médicaments on
parle formation médias de garderie et ce
genre de voir la réaction des agences de
crédit parce que ce soit pas demain la
veille qu'on va pouvoir balance un
budget à moins d'augmenter fardeau
fiscal d'une façon considérable il ya
déjà une agence qui a abaissé la note de
crédit c'est fitch est ce que les autres
agences pourraient le faire normalement
ya tant de dépôt d'un budget ou
peut-être de mise à jour budgétaire
qu'on pourrait avoir cet automne parce
que clairement pour faire une différence
entre un gouvernement qui se doit est
intervenu dans l'économie comme c'est le
cas actuellement pour venir soutenir les
entreprises très bonne nouvelle de
prolonger la bonne chose à faire
prolonger la subvention salariale parce
qu'encore une fois on a tous des raisons
de santé publique c'est des entreprises
doivent fermer des raisons de santé
publique c'est pas leur faut donc si les
travailleurs doivent retrouver leur
emploi est fou quand on soutient de
l'entreprise mais c'est une autre paire
de manches que d'afficher ses couleurs
pour dire voici à moyen long terme on
voit dans la chambre médicaments
et les choses que j'ai mentionnés et qui
plus est on va ajouter des nobles pour
au niveau des provinces le policier de
longue durée
donc la main on est ici en programmant
minoritaires période de quel côté qui
peut rester au pouvoir piller savoir
plutôt un ayant l'appui du npd donc un
peu plus d'interventions dans l'économie
et il faudra voir comment tout ça va se
financer mais on ne va pas se prépare je
serais très étonnée qu'on ait des
réponses est-ce qu'on va réussir avec
cette intervention et cette politique
interventionniste a créé ce million
d'emplois dont on parle est aujourd'hui
il manque encore un million cent mille
emplois par rapport à la situation du
mois de février est ce que c'est
possible de retrouver ses jambes ses
emplois tant qu'on est dans une
situation toujours d'état d'urgence en
quelque sorte mais c'est ça aussi ça
dépend de l'horizon de temps qu'on a
science donne 3 1 je conviens que l'on
va avoir trouvé un médicament un vaccin
plusieurs ont retrouvé deux emplois mais
certains ne retrouvons pas deux ans
pourrait postuler
ils ont fêté dans voilée dans la
nouvelle économie une développement plus
avec des technologies vertes et tout
temps que c'est très louable mais
clairement pour avoir aussi au niveau
d'aidé des individus parce que là il ya
beaucoup de mesures sont temporaires qui
seront pas renouvelés donc c'est un plan
ambitieux je le répète si on regarde par
le passé bien que cette restitution des
états type et ça prend quand même
plusieurs années est ce qu'on retrouve
le niveau d'emploi qu'on avait l'an
dernier où l on pourrait voir ceci on a
besoin de 3 4 1 pour retrouver une
volant fois de 2009 alors sur le plan
économique on va terminer là dessus je
lisais récemment des économistes qu'ils
avaient finalement là la chute
économique sera peut-être un peu moins
forte cette année on aura un rebond bon
en 2021
vous voyez quoi là par rapport à tout ce
qui se passe les remontées de cas de
covin notamment mais brillamment
retournera pas dans le confinement là
comme on a vu au printemps dernier aux
mains de cet homme un futur et
consultante est permis donc c'est la
phase de récupération dans lesquels on
est maintenant et c'est pas de
récupération doit par contre être
beaucoup plus longue sur une deuxième
pack devient très important et que les
gens sont pas très disciplinés là ce
moment là ce pourrait prendre beaucoup
plus de temps et ça vaut aussi à 15
vaccin vote et ce qui est distribué à
grande échelle et tout cela pourrait
nous amener à la fin de 2021 donc avant
que vous voyez leur offre un retour à la
normale on parle de 3,4 bon alors c'est
sur cette note que je ne devrais pas
note d'espoir mais le réalisme de votre
part merci clément gignac au plaisir